so Rob it must be pretty amazing to be
in the land of Pokemon right now and and
like getting to premiere to this movie
here that's so cool I love Tokyo yeah I
love it's such a great city it plays an
important role in the movie because our
world of prime city is truly a mash-up
of London New York and Tokyo yeah and
try to kind of this east-meets-west vibe
of it and it was very much inspired by
you know all the trips I've made back
and forth to Tokyo
yes Japanese culture and I grew up in
Hawaii and that there's a big Asian
influence and I just loved the idea of
bridging those two worlds in in in this
movie yeah it's an amazing world that
you guys have created there seeing the
Pokemon like come to life so to speak is
like for anyone who's watched the
cartoon growing up they're gonna lose
their minds I think when they yeah what
was the process like designing just
deciding what things work and look like
deciding which Pokemon get to be in the
film well the process was daunting be as
it's a worldwide phenomenon and ya know
there's a lot of people of all ages all
the way into their 30s who you know care
deeply about Pokemon we work very
closely with the Pokemon company with
the original creators with the original
designers Ken Sugimori who drew you know
Pikachu yeah we sent the concept art
directly to him he oversaw it on that
team at Game Freak which is the guys who
he oversees we went back and forth with
them a lot all the Pokemon company
people were on set so it was a real
truly collaboration with the Pokemon
company and everyone on the crew you
know we had it to my surprise
Millennials like have a deep love for
Pokemon so love our crew members like
they grew up on this so everyone put a
lot of care into the film wasn't really
exciting for everyone to be involved in
what was it about Ryan Reynolds that
makes them like the perfect detective
Pikachu well Ryan's Hilaire
yes we we were looking for a big
personality
mhmmm to occupy a very little package
right little yellow package and someone
who could do comedy and heart at the
same time and that sorta narrows it down
yeah and Ryan so gifted at both and I
love AB living and improving and I you
know I'm a huge fan of his but we
cheated a little bit we took a clip of
before Ryan was involved in one of his
old movies an animated Pikachu to that
clip yeah and the second we saw with his
voice coming out he just knew I mean it
was a no-brainer yes he was perfect for
this and it just really feels natural he
just fits into it so yeah so if you
could choose your favorite Pokemon like
a top three of your favorite what would
your top three favorites be top three
yeah well it's gotta be Pikachu yeah cuz
my career is depending on ya mu - yeah
cuz you choose rad yeah he's also
appears in the movie yeah and then
Psyduck is a personal favorite because I
identify with Psyduck right Lina
stressed out you I get stressed out my
head explodes also and I like I'm like
this all the time now your son is here
just off that's my son who has he seen
the film yet he snuck in on one of his
days off at school when I was working
and and just plopped down and just
watched it he hasn't watched it he
watched in reels and we're still working
yeah so he hasn't watched as a whole
movie with the final sound yeah and and
so far from him thumbs up yeah I don't
know it's right there like yeah wicked
well listen we're really excited for
this
you